عندما نظرنا إلى معاناة
الأصدقاء
الفلسطينيين، رأينا
سمات مماثلة لما يمر به الفلسطينيون،
حيث إن ما نمر به نحن كجنوب
أفريقيين
من خلال الاتفاقية يجسد
التزامًا عالميًا جديدًا بضمان عدم
تعرض أي شخص مرة أخرى أبدًا
رعب
الإبادة الجماعية، للأسف، نحن في خطر
نسيان الدروس المظلمة من الماضي.
أعتقد أن ما أدركه المحامون ومليارات
الأشخاص في جميع أنحاء العالم والدول في
الجنوب والشرق العالمي
هو أننا لا نستطيع أن نثق في
أننا لا نستطيع  ننتظر ولا يمكننا الاعتماد
على المؤسسات الغربية رقم واحد سواء
كانت أمريكية كندية أو أوروبية ولا
يمكننا الاعتماد على الأمم المتحدة أو المحكمة الجنائية الدولية للقيام
بدور فعال في وقف
هذه الإبادة الجماعية التي تحدث أمام
أعيننا، ما يجب أن
يحدث حقًا  الأول هو فهم أن
ما يحدث في فلسطين
كان بمثابة إبادة جماعية تدريجية منذ عام 1948،
لذلك عندما يتم الاستناد إلى اتفاقية مناهضة الإبادة الجماعية،
فيجب أن يعود تاريخها إلى
الوقت الذي بدأت فيه الإبادة الجماعية المتزايدة،
فلا يوجد نقص في بيانات
نوايا الإبادة الجماعية للفلسطينيين الذين
لا تعترف AC
بجرائم الحرب المعترف بها عالميًا وجرائم الحرب المعترف بها
على وجه التحديد، قم بتأشيرة
الفلسطينيين من خلال قرارات الأمم المتحدة المختلفة،
فنحن نشاهد جنوب إفريقيا
وأعتقد أنه ستكون هناك حكومات أخرى
تنظر إلى محكمة
العدل الدولية ومحكمة العدل الدولية ومحكمة
العدل الدولية  أكثر استجابة للجمعية العامة للأمم المتحدة من
مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة، مما يتيح المجال
لدول جنوب
وشرق العالم لعرض قضايا
أمامها وإصدار قرارات
يمكن بعد ذلك استخدامها أيضًا في
المحاكم المحلية  المحاكم الوطنية في كل
دولة ولكنها تستخدم أيضًا للضغط على
المحكمة الجنائية الدولية أيضًا لرفع القضايا، فمن
المهم جدًا أن يقوم الناس في جميع أنحاء العالم
الذين تكون بلدانهم طرفًا في
اتفاقية الإبادة الجماعية بمطالبة جماعات الضغط
والمدافعة بأن تلجأ حكوماتهم إلى
تفعيل اتفاقية مناهضة الإبادة الجماعية
في
الأمم المتحدة